e
[Música]
eu sempre gostei de um palco de um
microfone e de uma plateia Eu sempre me
senti não apenas a vontade mas está
diante de um grupo de pessoas e ter algo
importante para dizer a ela sempre foi
uma alegria para mim eu aprendi muito
cedo que existem várias maneiras de
falar então na escola eu fiz teatro
artesanato fiz dança eu sempre soube que
o nosso corpo também tem algo a dizer
depois eu me apaixonei pela literatura
pela poesia pelos escritores eu adorava
que eles escreviam nos livros para mim é
porque a minha relação era mais ou menos
assim eu lia e achava que tava
conversando com os autores
e de repente me descrevendo também
comecei pela poesia os professores que
vinham que eu escrevia e que liam os
meus textos começaram a me incentivar a
mostrar aquilo que eu fazia então eu
passei a
frequentar concursos e mostras de poesia
eu confesso que eu sempre gostei muito
mais das mostras do que dos concursos é
que nos concursos quem se classificavam
para as etapas finais ou quem vencia
acabava subindo no palco e declamando a
sua poesia
algumas vezes eu tive essa oportunidade
mas quando eu chegava lá em cima no
palco na frente do microfone e olhava
para a plateia
e não era grande a plateia nunca era mas
eu consegui identificar
aquelas carinhas de outros jovens poetas
que também participavam do concurso
assim como eu mas que não tinham sido
classificados
é aquilo não fazia muito sentido para
mim porque eu havia me conectado com
algumas poesias eu havia lido e Muitas
delas tinha me tocado profundamente
a poesia é uma experiência emocional
interna e individual o poeta usa a
linguagem da alma fala direto com o
coração eu não entendia para mim não
fazia o menor sentido aquele julgamento
e ainda muito jovem na pré-adolescência
eu já tinha um espírito crítico muito
aguçado eu acredito que foram os
próprios livros que me apresentaram de
modo precoce os problemas da humanidade
as questões sociais
desde menina eu com nove dez anos já
devorava livros a minha mãe tinha em
casa uma coleção de clássicos da Abril
Cultural enorme era uma coleção que
tinha uns 30 livros mais ou menos e eu
li quase todos me lembro ainda que
alguns títulos como a comédia humana
Admirável Mundo Novo O Morro dos Ventos
Uivantes tinha também os irmãos
karamazov de Dostoiévski Os Contos de
Voltaire e tantos outros toda essa
experiência Acabou me aproximando da
filosofia do pensamento e dos seus
desdobramentos
eu tinha um sonho naquela época um
desejo enorme eu queria ser importante
ter importância a transformar o mundo EA
vida das pessoas bom gente transformar o
mundo é até um sonho próprio da
adolescência
mas fato é que a adolescência passou e
esse sonho continua comigo
então eu imaginava naquela época que eu
poderia me tornar uma advogada ou talvez
uma promotora de justiça e que assim eu
teria a chance de ocupar espaços onde eu
poderia
defender alguns direitos humanos e
também deveres porque eu sempre achei
que os deveres são extremamente
importantes para todos os cidadãos
É mas eu não sei se eu conseguiria de
fato movimentar platéias tocar corações
eo das situações que naquela época já me
incomodavam então veio ensino médio eu
me aproximei ainda mais o estudo da arte
descobrir outras formas de expressão
descobrir também que nós interagimos com
os lugares por onde passamos e nós criam
e Sensações e somos capazes de
transformar ambientes em espaços cheios
de significados como eu me dava muito
bem com cálculos com a matemática e era
apaixonada pela arte que eu pensei então
que talvez eu pudesse me dar bem no
caminho da arquitetura e eu tava certa
que sim acabei me inscrevendo então no
vestibular para o curso de arquitetura
e mais no fundo eu não estava assim tão
certa refazendo os cálculos analisando a
rota
ajustando as velas eu descobri que
talvez eu pudesse Navegar por outros
mares e me inscrevi então para uma
seleção na Marinha do Brasil
mas naquela maré de incertezas cheia de
dúvidas e informações fragmentadas
e eu resolvi olhar um pouquinho por que
acontecia ao redor daquele período a
democracia EA nova constituição federal
estavam em debate a liberdade de
expressão em Alta ai eu gostei daquele
cenário e foi assim que eu acabei
escrevendo no outro vestibular para o
curso de jornalismo
é mas tem um detalhe curioso nessa
história que eu faço um parênteses aqui
é que a nova constituição federal que já
nem é tão nova assim ela foi promulgada
no dia cinco de Outubro de1988
naquela data era meu aniversário eu
completava 18 anos e eu entendi então
que aquele dia eu e o Brasil conquistar
vamos alguma autonomia
Ou pelo menos no papel né gente mas eu
sabia também que autonomia exigiria ação
atitude
responsabilidade e tomada de decisões
e com todos os sonhos ali colocados à
prova eu comecei a ter que fazer
escolhas a primeira dela as provas dos
vestibulares de jornalismo de
arquitetura que seriam em instituições
diferentes foram marcadas para o mesmo
dia eu não tive a menor dúvida que eu
escolhi o jornalismo
a comunicação e tudo que é de interesse
da alma humana já estavam presentes no
Meu DNA e o resultado
aprovação do vestibular saiu num dia e
no dia seguinte a convocação para uma
segunda fase na seleção da Marinha do
Brasil mas ali eu já estava bem certa
filmar pelo menos para mim seria um
lugar só para passar as férias o
jornalismo foi a minha escola meu
alimento minha inspiração o ar que eu
respirava na TV na reportagem onde eu
vivi por vinte e oito anos eu realizei
grandes sonhos conhecer boa parte do
Brasil Atravessei e
mergulhei nas profundezas do ser humano
conhecia acredito quase todas as dores
mas também as maiores alegrias desse
mundo as grandes conquistas grandes
vitórias as descobertas da ciência os
tesouros da natureza
é
mas eu também
me senti muito de perto da angústia à
dor das frustrações e das tragédias
enumeras delas e onde quer que eu
estivesse independente da história que
eu tinha para contar eu sempre me
lembrava daqueles jovens poetas que
participavam dos concursos de poesia
junto comigo e que não tiveram a chance
de passar a sua mensagem
dispor os seus pensamentos de falar uma
pena de escrever uma poesia mas poder
verbalizar o que eles sentiram
Eu já havia descoberto que para
transformar é preciso falar é preciso
ter voz Sim é preciso ter voz e todas as
vezes que eu tive a chance de falar de
ser a voz de uma comunidade ou de um
determinado grupo Eu sempre procurei por
uma plateia não porque eu queria ser
vista assim no palco não nada disso
é mas assim como nos concursos de poesia
eu queria saber se a minha mensagem
fazia sentido se ela era capaz de tocar
corações e transformar sentimentos
pensamentos
e talvez até o mundo de algumas pessoas
durante toda minha trajetória como
repórter os 28 anos em que o atuei como
jornalista de televisão eu sempre olhei
com muito carinho para essa história e
para as pessoas com quem eu me conectava
a todos os dias invariavelmente quando
eu chegar vai redação e me deparava com
a falta ao perceber ao descobrir o
assunto ali que eu teria para tratar eu
fazia algumas perguntas para mim mesma
e o que isso aqui é importante a quem
interessa
o que partir do momento que nós
mostravam nessa história essa situação
na TV
O Que mudanças podem acontecer na vida
dessas pessoas e se ocorrerem mudança
será que elas vão ser positiva
e sempre que eu tive a chance de falar
eu me lembrava daqueles jovens que não
tiveram vó que não tiveram um Palco o
microfone e nenhuma plateia mas muitos
deles tinham mensagens Profundas para
passar e talvez houvesse em provocar
mudança
e por isso eu digo agora que é preciso
falar sim nós precisamos falar mas antes
saber o que dizer para saber o que dizer
nós precisamos primeiro ouvir mas ouvir
a nossa própria avó Sim você precisa
ouvir a sua própria avó essa voz que
grita aí dentro de você dizendo quem
você é o que é que você busca essa voz
que vai ajudar a organizar os
pensamentos os sentimentos e mostrar
para você do que você é capaz Sim você
precisa ouvir a sua própria avó e depois
falar mesmo que não haja Falco nem
microfone nem plateia nenhum concurso
mesmo que não haja uma câmera ligada
apontando para você e dizendo estamos ao
vivo para Talvez um milhão 2 milhões 10
milhões de pessoas ouvirem aquilo que
temos para falar o que não haja nada
disso sim é preciso dizer é preciso
falar mas antes precisamos ouvir a nossa
para vó e talvez você esteja aí se
perguntando Mas como isso é possível e
eu digo Calma calma
e respira
a respirar
[Música]
e é esse movimento que nós fazemos desde
o nosso primeiro instante de vida nesse
mundo que começa a organizar as coisas
aqui dentro é esse movimento que nós
fazemos sem pensar de forma automática
aliás nós vivemos no piloto automático
mas é importante olhar também para o que
é automático para saber se tudo está
funcionando bem
bom então inspira respira
e quando você respira tudo se acalma o
coração se aquieta E é assim que você
vai começar a ouvir essa vó que grita aí
dentro de você e que assim sendo vó a
minha a sua o a voz de uma geração
inteira Que ela possa ir com ar espalhar
tocar milhares de ouvidos e Decorações
E se for assim essa voz pode ser mais
uma força capaz de transformar o mundo
porque sim a sua avó é um instrumento de
transformação acredite
é
muito obrigado